[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
le retirer
je n'ai pas juste un problème de
violence simple violence parce que nous
sommes des humains on nous tue parce que
nous sommes noirs
hu
ça a fait réagir beaucoup sur les
réseaux sociaux les jeunes sur plein de
plate forme et je pense aussi parce que
c'était un meurtre particulièrement
horrible et est atroce et je pense que
là on s'est dit c'est plus possible en
fait il faut il faut qu'on arrête ces on
peut pas et nous en tant que blanc enfin
pour la plupart en tant que blanc
privilégiés on s'est dit on a une voix
il faut qu'on s'en serve pour la donner
pour ce mouvement là quoi c'est super
important
[Applaudissements]
tous
t'as pas laisser passer ça les gens qui
meurent sous les balles des plages
gaulle
des jeunes gens qui meurent sur un
contrôle de police je ne peux pas très
des parts dans les fruits et me
considéraient les ferias n'a pas trouvé
pourquoi je connais un gars y'a pas ce
qu'on veut mais moi c'est pas juste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]